hey everybody i'm alex and i'm here with
Michael one of the developers of bound a
ps4 ps4 exclusive yeah anything so we're
going to be playing to one of the levels
of bound tell me a little bit about
what's going on here in this level so
this is one of the levels of our game
and so so basically the thing the
another unique thing about our game is
that you decide which level to play
first and which level to play last so I
can't tell you actually if it's a first
or the second or the last level it's up
to you to decide and because of that
there are several things that I will try
to show you which might be interesting
so this game isn't when you're
necessarily it isn't in terms of like
the the pure gameplay and in terms of
the story so there are like 120 ways to
pass the game and it will like influence
the story but it's it's not like in this
way that you have like 120 combinations
and like choices in the end but rather
it's it's something that the story will
unfold in a different old order so you
will have a different view on that and
the idea behind it was like it's came
from journey because this is the game
that I really like and I was playing it
on in the various time so when it on
lunch and when there was like a ps4
version and I thought that it's like
it's different because of the
multiplayer factor but it looked the
same so what I wanted to do is to figure
out the way for reply abilities so when
you will play bounding like in three
years or maybe in ten years then it will
look completely different and you may
have like a different view on this
and this is because you're like aging
and there are some movies that when you
were watching like when I was watching
as being a teenager I had a completely
different view on them and when I was
watching them recently my view
completely changed so this is something
that we wanted to have here it's based
on the on the order the view on the
story changes and also like in time it
may change because you are changing and
I heard you say once and blonde jealous
I was watching that you would you think
this game might be good as adults only
yes but I can elaborate more on that and
because we were making play tests on
like on a different a lot of people and
I think that that's a it's hard to say
it's like a good game for everybody but
not adults like they will have different
view on the understory like adults will
have different view on the story and
like teenagers will have different view
on the story and I hope that the view
will change in time so one day the
teenagers will become adults them then
they will have like also different view
on that so yeah I I've changed that but
this story is like serious one is like a
major one and how exactly is the story
going to be presented because I noticed
in another level that I was finding that
there was a sort of cuts he knows more
realistic you know you actually saw
faces it was a memory so yeah we call
them memories and this is like one way
that we told this story and based on
those memories you will be able like to
get into it so it's pretty nonlinear and
this is like the trunks it's not like a
game where the story is
being tall but it's like the game the
game where the story is being shown so
so that that's a little difference and
also like a big difference and yeah and
the very important thing about the story
is that we can't tell anything about it
because when you will know actually
what's going on before playing it then
it may not trigger and we had like a
play testers that were like very
emotionally connected to dead to the
character and mostly because they didn't
know what their the water they will be
playing so right now we can see like the
the ballerina dancer a character in an
abstract world but it's not a game about
dancing but the movement is very dense
inspired you have a hands like I notice
you know defending yourself you you
dance right it's like a know what we
call this like a resolution to problems
like the dance is a solution for for
problems and those things that stop you
in the game we call them fierce so here
for example is a fear that we call a
steam like a snake esteem it looks a
little bit different than regular steam
but we got it like that and what was the
inspiration for making the movement as
games based as it is so it's it's pretty
simple actually so we have the character
than before and we have like that the
system of walking around but we can get
this like really harsh feedback that
okay so you get it working but it's it
looks like a character from a game and
it's like we are making a game and it
looks like character from the games like
what's going on and actually it's is it
sad truth in that currently there are so
many games like hundreds of games
released every day so you need to find
something unique to like to be visible
and and then we discovered that when we
so the idea for the for the dancer came
from my friend who sent me like a video
clip we were dancing the girl I can a
contemporary dance and this is like wow
from the waist how she moves it
completely matches the character in
terms of the story so we should like
pursue that in that direction but it was
like not not the thing that we started
for from so we didn't start from the
dance but it's a nice addition if you
think about the dancing characters in
games what came to my mind after doing
that is that it's I won't say that there
is no single game with dancing character
but there's like maybe a dozen of that
in terms of the history of all game and
like dancing is with with people from
the very beginning so it's quite weird
and I think it's like how many things we
didn't discover and put into the games
that can be discovered like the ideas
are like on the ground you just need to
Thanks so how do you how do you unify
all those different ideas if you know
the like because there are a lot of very
disparate inspirations in this game that
I'm already noticing from the visual
style to the sound yes it's we were
thinking about it and it's mostly like
by brute force like trying a lot of
things and like throwing them out it's
not like we asked start from beginning
we actually don't work with a concept
artists except for the characters we're
mostly making constant in with
programming and code and the idea for
like the shuttering world like how it
looks it came from like a demo scene
like the pieces around but actually we
what we were doing is I was creating
this character movement and asked my
friend to like visualize the physical
boxes that I work on and when he did it
I asked for her shadows so to know where
I'm going and then I says like wow it's
actually we're pretty close we can studs
the lobby okay and and then we started
to shatter those boxes because it was
like the idea for the story that the
word gets smaller and smaller and
smaller in time like it dissolves in
front of your eyes so the world will
change yes it will change and this is
something that I plan to show you after
finishing this level um yeah could you
talk a little bit about the art style
because this is a very distinctive yeah
so this is the outside is very inspired
by by modern art and Deimos seen in the
most in terms of programming and modern
art in terms of like a a lead a very
minimalistic style for example those
lines that are here
on those blocks and this is like the
taken from the art movement like
suprematism competition and no plaid
class citizen and each level is
connected for to each of those movements
so in this case with that we have those
stripes which are resembling but we also
have seen couple of of statues and make
from blog so we try to put something in
each level which will be like
distinctive circle would be able to say
it's like oh this is the level with that
and this is the level with that and
other than that it would be like another
blocky level and I have another level
with cubes so we had to do that I
actually showed one of the previous
demos a video of it to my friend who's
an art historian Linda and she said that
it looks like if you stuck a game
designer in an art museum and then told
them to recreate it and you know a video
game is that something that you're going
for yeah i've already got contacted by a
man whose museum to put it in there for
an exposition which is really nice and
and what why not it's like a visual
style is still under like evolution is
still like going on and like vr would
probably show a couple of new styles
that will appear because they will be
created in VR so yeah it's it's
evolutionary I think that there is a lot
of styles that can be created ok so
we've reached an like a moment in the
game where we are trying to show the
next piece of the story so the story is
a is conveyed to subtle images like that
yeah also are also by that but here's
another memory steam okay so uh what's
going on here yeah it's it's for you to
like explore and figure out like the
facts like connect the the character is
like make connections between it's like
what's their relations between them and
no it's it's mostly like that I I will
tell you that you're just playing at
rank of the game so it will not like
spoil your experience but trust me it's
it's not like a super esoteric artsy
game that it's really hard to dig into
we've made a lot of play tests and
taters to like exactly new what's what
the story was about so can you talk at
all about how this these play into the
game and I'm like how I I don't want to
it's because it will destroy the
experience for players and and this is
the only way that they can connect
emotionally to the story if they don't
know what they are going to experience
okay yeah this is wildly different than
when i was just playing the first person
in slow moving everything is sort of you
know solidifying around me as i move
through it and yeah it's going to be
interesting to see how this plays into
the other part of the game and i come
did you like it in VR this part oh yeah
it was it was really cool um because
there's like a camera movement yeah in
first-person perspective but yeah that
actually brings up something else I want
to ask you about this is coming to PS VR
could you talk a little bit about your
decision to bring it yeah so it's coming
on the psv our lounge and it will be
like a free patch on when it will be
lunched so so and the idea behind like
making the VR version like from came
from very very beginning and so I was
thinking that it could be done like the
third person camera in VR it's something
that it's possible okay and and it works
and I think it's like a very generic
solution that what we do with camera so
like the other games I think like for
example and uncharted and other TPP
games can be easily transformed into VR
and yeah and I'm really interested in
how people will will see it and is there
anything okay i will i will like your
top here this is the moment that I
wanted to take control so we played
through the whole level and I would like
to show you how this level will look
like when it was but it wouldn't be
chosen as the first one so that you can
choose the levels in a different order
but the time moves like in a normal
fashion so the time changes and right
now there will be rain falling because
it's like in a different place of time
but it's a great exactly the same level
so we can see that the monster is is
coming in the same way but I but it
looks completely different it has a
different palette it has like a
different destruction structure so right
now the world is dissolved even more and
it's like like it's disappears but what
I would like to show you right now is
the like the other part of the game
before that we're talking most about the
story the statics and we have a puzzle
in the game because you it went through
the level very easily like there was no
challenge at all but actually for me
puzzles are are something that are that
I don't like if I know them so if I
plagued the puzzle before it becomes a
work so you know you see the path things
like I ok I need to put it here and here
so we are making work so we're thinking
of how to make a puzzle that will be
actually interesting in terms of that
will be unique and the funny thing is
that we don't know the the actual
solution for it so we want players to
discover it do you think it's solvable
yes it is it's just it's just a matter
of like a lot of flight rules and like a
statistics and and we'll see I think
they will solve it pretty quickly so I
you've seen that I was like the world
damping here to find another path of
that level and now i will show you the
move that you didn't discover and we
didn't show it on purpose so there is
like a small hint in the very first
tutorial level about that because there
are places that you can't jump normally
you need to discover they're all jumping
and right now we can like move in the
different parts of the game so for
example let's try to do here go here
and I can't go there because there's
this team that you already seen and it
calls the the passage so i won't be able
to go here but we'll go back to to that
point later on so you can't get there
just I'll i can get there but i will
show you the other places that i can get
okay so we'll pass the monster right now
and we reach that point where there was
pleased that were like holding you and
right now the trees are like become
let's let's say like over camp and they
will disappear and will no longer hold
you and what sure is that in that that
triggers like the order of the levels so
so in in every other you like taking
care of one of your fears so playing the
levels and different orders will open up
different passages exactly and right now
we have get a good rid of the trees so
let's try to move here okay but the
steam is still there
and there are trees and if you will work
over here then you will discover that
there were trees that they are no longer
here ah I've missed
and aww that's the tricky one
here got it arc I if one thing to notice
is like when you die for the first time
like when we fall for the first time
then the animation of falling is pretty
long and it gets shorter and shorter so
the penalty for falling ha got it oh no
no no no hahaha I will find another
passage to do it so bad please ok but
that
yes got it okay let's go here and we are
on top of that level which moves us to
the spheres and actually you have to go
around this whole building to get here
and I will just work on those fears so
the spheres is something that I was
always missing in games because I like
to play mario galaxy you can jump from
spirit of fear I'm not too good at it
but if you are good then you can really
jump very fast from Montana up so there
are very different difficulty yes and if
you will go through the spheres like
there's a lot of spheres and you will
cut the level in half but i will show
you another another version of the same
level if you will choose the level as
the last one then the other fields will
disappear and right now we will have we
won't have the steam which was holding
can t as in the very beginning so other
passages will open so the version of the
level that I played is that would that
have been if you had picked it at the
beginning yes so everything goes on okay
so it's not like yeah everything was
locked practically but there are still
shortcuts that you can use even if the
level was chosen as first so for example
you can make some things that we call a
sequence breakers so sequence breakers
are actually trying to omit the whole
cutscene that sits in the level you can
go around it so the cutscene won't i
won't appear but it's these are the
short short cuts that are the hardest to
find ok so we are going through here and
are there some cutscenes that only
trigger if you go certain ways with
alone yes ok but normally if you will
pass it through the first playthrough
you will get through them all there we
really
done well okay so let's jump here and we
can go here and because of that we can
completely skip the monster
over here
escape and here will be another tricky
jump okay all right
let's try it again so basically this
time this shortcut works because I I've
removed like all all the viewers sorry
can it try to do it slowly this time
ok
and there's a letter where I will show
you that we are on top of the place
where the trees were so another ladder
has been opened here and now there are
perils that we're also holding but
they're gone now so right now we've
reached the end of the level so we cut
cut it down completely and there is like
a 120 combinations to pass through the
game and we don't know which one is the
fastest and we don't know it's like
because we didn't pursue it we wanted to
leave it to the players but we know that
there are balanced so when we were
trying to find the path that it's like
outstanding from the others than we were
balancing it and I think they are nicely
balanced so I hope that the players will
will find it that thanks Michael that
was a few levels of bound or a few
playthroughs of the same level of bound
and do you is there any release date for
that its 16th of august and you can
pre-order it now in the play promotion
together with other games and it the psv
our patch will be available on PS vita
start on frightened of september-october
October great thank you very much that
was really cool and keep an eye on
gamespot for more about bound in the
coming months
you